I remember when I remember when, I remember, I remember I lost my mind.
I think I'm crazy. Na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, dieser neuen Folge. Wir machen heute mal ein bisschen eine Wellnessfolge, eine Entspannungsfolge. Wir lehnen uns heute mal ein bisschen weiter zurück. Wir haben auf unserem Bürosessel einfach mal den Hahn gedrückt und die Schwerkraft Schwerkraft machen lassen und sind entspannt, denn Stefan Titzel sitzt neben mir.
Und Florentin Willi sitzt gegenüber von mir. Ich freue mich auf diese, ich nenne sie immer,
die nächste Folge, diese berühmte Folge 49, wo wir uns zurückgenommen haben, in unseren Raum gezogen haben,
den wir sonst auch immer aufnehmen. Es kann nichts schiefgehen, die Aufnahme, das Mikro ist geputzt, blank geputzt. Ich freue mich einfach. Wir haben Wasser, ich habe eine Salamimi-Combo, so eine Art Bifirol in Scheisse. Ich muss sagen, ich rieche da sowohl, also ich rieche da sehr viel Salami raus, aber auch eine Menge viel Kauf, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Diese Bifirol ist für mich immer so ein Ding. Ich rieche da keinen Salami mehr raus, weil so lange eingeschweißt ist, kann nicht mehr Salami sein. Zumal man auch nicht genau weiß, woraus dieser Teig ist, weil das ist ja offensichtlich kein Brot oder irgendein Erzeugnis, dass irgendwas mit Getreide im weitesten Sinne zu tun hat. Vor allem diese Löcher, die da reingesteckt sind immer. Ja, genau. Wofür sind die gut, damit die Salami atmen kann? Nee, damit man da Senf reintun kann. Ja. Nee, aber ganz im Ernst, nämlich die gab es auch beim Aldi, diese Saletti oder heißen die dann sowas, diese Beefies halt, sagen wir es mal Beefies. Salamini. Und die gab es auch in Teigmantel, aber da war immer so ein Hohlraum noch neben der Wurst und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das dafür gedacht ist. Es war einfach ein Hotdog, es war einfach offen. Ne, aber ich habe das dafür gedacht, dass man einfach Senf da noch rein tun kann, weil man auch die gute alte Salami auch mal gerne mit Senf isst und das ist, finde ich, ein guter Weg, dieses geniale Produkt noch zu verbessern.
Wir sind gut drauf, liebe Zuhörer und Zuhörerinnen.
Oh, und ich habe gerade gemerkt, dass ich aus Versehen eine Datei gelöscht habe, aber es ist nicht so wild.
Wir sind gut drauf, weil wir eben ein Frettchen gesehen haben.
Ja, und in der Hand hatten sie.
Wir hatten ein kleines Frettchen in der Hand.
Ist das großartig.
Es war eine Sie, aber nicht gemerkt.
Ich habe unter das Fell und Rock gucken wollen, aber habe es nicht gesehen. Es war ein sehr kleines Geschöpf, sehr niedlich, es beißt nicht, es war so sücht, dass man dachte, wow, ich hätte auch gerne so eins, bis wir erfahren haben, was es frisst. Es frisst Babyküken. Ja, nicht nur Küken, sondern Babyküken. Sondern Babyküken. Kleine Babyküken. Und die flogen dann da rum im Büro, die waren eingefroren. Die waren eingefroren. Ja, vor allem was die schon durchgemacht haben. Erstmal werden die geboren, was schon mal scheiße ist, dann werden die mehr oder weniger instant vergast. Schock gefroren. Ne, die werden erstmal vergast, weil du ja glaube ich nur die Weibchen überhaupt brauchen kannst, weil aus denen dann Eier letztlich produziert werden. Da werden die Füsse abgehackt und die werden dann eingestampft und aus denen werden dann Eierschalen gemacht. Und die Jungs werden vergast, ja. Die Jungs werden entweder komplett zerschreddert sofort oder vergast und dann gefroren und dann tatsächlich verkauft als Futter. Frettchenfutter. Vor allem, also ich hätte nie, also ich dachte immer, Evolution funktioniert so, dass süße Tiere von weniger süssen Tieren gefressen werden. Also eine Maus ist sehr süss, wird gefressen von einer Katze, ist süss, wird gefressen von einem Geparden, der ist schon weniger süss, der wird gefressen von einem Pfann. Also je kleiner Tiere werden, desto süsser werden sie. Jetzt muss ich aber feststellen, Frettchen fressen Küken und Frettchen sind süsser als Küken. Also was ist da los? Frettchen fressen Küken, fressen... Fressen Körner. Ich dachte, da liegt irgendwie so eine Art So Zungenbrecher oder so. Frechen fressen, Frauen, Frechen fressen, Frauen, Frost. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, vor 20 Folgen hast du gesagt, du versuchst bei jeder Story den Comedy-Aspekt zu finden. Mittlerweile hast du das aufgegeben, du suchst die Zungenbrecher mittlerweile. Ich suche, genau, ich suche schwierig ausgesprechende Wörter und verbinde sie. Alterationsfreak halt.
Was darfst du sagen? Nee, aber das Ding ist, dass die Küken nicht lebend verfüttert werden können, obwohl das Frettchen viel lieber lebend füttern würde. Meine Frage dann fand ich, zu Recht greift man damit nicht massiv in die Natur ein mit dem Gesetz, weil die ja nicht lebend verfüttert werden könnten, obwohl das Frettchen es lieben würde. Ja, aber vor allem, ich meine, wie konnten die Frettchen sich evolutionär entwickeln, wenn sie nur Küken fressen konnten? Also nur die Babys von, was sind das, Pfau, glaube ich, wo Küken entstehen? Straussen, Vogelstraussen. Straussen. Funktioniert das so oder ist das ein Luxusding, dass sie sich jetzt, früher haben sie noch irgendwie so Wurzeln gegessen und so Ingwer und irgendwie Orangenschalen oder sowas. Hauptsächlich Vegan, es waren Veganer, militant. Genau, aber jetzt können sie es auch leisten, weil sie mehr Geld verdienen. Frettchen sind ja sehr gute Verdiener tatsächlich im Tierreich, glaube ich, alle der unter den Top Ten. Das sind so ein bisschen, das sind so, sagen wir mal, die wohl noch so im Hollywood des Tierreichs. Ja. Bei, sagen wir mal, Leuten, die es auch an Film- und Fernsehproduktionsfirmen verschenken. Meinst du, es gibt unter Frettchen auch eine Initiative, dass sie nicht mehr Frettchen, sondern nur noch Frett genannt werden möchten? Genau. Weil Frettchen ist ja beleidigt. Wir wollen diese Verniedlichung nicht mehr. Ja, weg mit dem Chenn. Wir sind Frette. Glaubst du, dass sich Mädchen irgendwann mal so sehr emanzipieren, dass es nur noch Mad heisst? Mad werden. Mad. Mad Mädchen? Jungs und Mads. Madde. Madder. Maddel. Madde. Madde. Aber tatsächlich muss man ja mal sagen, warum hatten wir überhaupt Frettchen da? Weil wir vor drei Tagen zusammengesassen sind und dachten uns... Zusammengesassen sind? Wow, das was Sie hörten, ist das wieder kein Dialekt, ist einfach nur falsch. Vom Morgen ist ein Zungenbrecher. Du hast mich angesteckt mit deiner Zungenbrecher-Fan. Ich habe das Blitze in deinen Augen gesehen, weil wir einfach zusammensassen vor einem Text für die Sendung und dachten, Frettchen wäre noch lustig, oder? Und dann schreibt man da rein diese acht Buchstaben und drei Tage später ist dieses lebende Ding wirklich vor Ort. Du entdeckst gerade die geilen Momente des Autorendaseins. Genial. Du schreibst Dinge auf, einfach weil du manchmal auch Bock hast. Auch manchmal als Gag, so ist es gar nicht ernst gemeint. Du denkst manchmal einfach auf, jetzt ein goldener, vergoldeter Elefant, der durchs Publikum läuft. Und zack, müssen Leute arbeiten Nächte dafür. Deswegen haben wir auch so einen unfassbar schlechten, das ist wirklich auch kein Scherz, wir haben einen unfassbar schlechten Ruf in dieser Firma. Wir beiden im Speziellen, weil wir auch anderen Räume blockieren für unser seltsames Freizeitprojekt. Aber auch die Autoren selber, weil man sich halt irgendwie aus so Hirnfürzen Dinge rauskommen, wofür andere dann einfach monatelang einfach Nachtarbeiten schieben. Zum Beispiel auch das Dürrf-Example, die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse im Leben von, die erste Staffel, wo irgendwer gesagt hat, boah, jetzt ein Galgensketch oder so. Und die Idee war, glaube ich, erster, und einen Tag später stand ungelogen ein perfekter, funktionsfähiger Galgen auf dem Hof. Eine Guillotine, eine Fallbeil. Ja, so eine Guillotine, genau. Und einfach, wo auch theoretisch einfach ein Fallbeil oben runterkommen könnte und jemand köpfen könnte. Es war eine komplett einlandsfähige Guillotine. Ja, es ist genial, weil man immer... Jetzt glaube ich in Syrien oder so, haben wir nachher verkauft. Es wird gut verkauft worden, der Markt ist gerade da. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass man halt auch teilweise ironisch Dinge aufschreibt und einfach so als Gag schreibt und mal einfach so mal hinschreibt, weil es kostet ja nichts hinzuschreiben und Leute das einfach eins zu eins ernst nehmen.
Aber es kostet einen Elefanten zu buchen und das Publikum auch. Ja genau, das ist einfach machen, also das ist echt, wir haben schon ein ganz geiles Leben, Stefan, nicht wahr? Aber es ist doch wirklich so, du bist jetzt als Autor ja angefangen, richtig, du entdeckst langsam so die Vorteile daran, oder?
Ja.
Du entdeckst so, du bist so auf Logikäuersule, so glücklich durch die Flure läufst du noch so und fängst so Bürogespräche an. Du bist noch so ein ganz euphorischer Arbeiter, während ich schon weinend in der Ecke immer so erzählen. Ja, du bist schon zynisch geworden. Und dann mit meiner Aktentasche morgens um die Ecke kommen. Genau, du sagst, meine Ideen werden eh nicht genommen, die haben eh keine Ahnung, was lustig ist und was nicht. Und ich gehe noch wirklich mit viel Enthusiasmus ran und versuche die Leute auch ein bisschen kennenzulernen und so.
Tatsächlich, unser beider Kollege Max Bierhals hat am Anfang der Staffel gesagt, diese Staffel merke ich mir nicht mehr die Namen der Praktikanten. Und ich habe mir gesagt, nein, so will ich nicht werden. Ich will das genaue Gegenteil haben. Ich merke mir die Namen aller Praktikanten. Dafür meiner Kollegen nicht. Man muss ja nicht Prioritäten setzen. Und meinen eigenen Namen habe ich vergessen. Du, ich habe Folgendes haben wir ja gemacht. Wir haben ja unter der Woche, weil wir der Community was zurückzahlen wollten, haben wir unsere Jimmy-Kart-Tickets verlost.
Tatsächlich, was wahrscheinlich viele als Gag wahrgenommen haben und es gar nicht geglaubt haben, war tatsächlich so, denn Stefan hat in weisser Voraussicht, glaube ich, schon vor drei Monaten diese Karten gekauft, denn Jimmy Carr, ein grosser britischer Comedian, ist nach Köln gekommen, hat Karten gekauft, leider musste sich an dem Tag umziehen, war in Berlin und Stefan will nicht alleine gehen, weil das an seine Kindheit erinnert. Nee, ich konnte auch nicht, weil ich hatte plötzlich ein Date. Und warum bist du dann nicht mit deinem Date dahingegangen? Die kann kein Englisch. Aber es war noch untertitelt alles. Sie kann auch, sie ist blind. Das erklärt einiges. Eine blinde Ausländerin. Das ist hart, blinde Ausländerin, tatsächlich. Ja. Und weiter jetzt. Und folgendes habe ich jetzt eben mal in Erfahrung gebracht. Ich habe die Nummer von unserem Gewinner, die Handynummer, und ich dachte, wir berufen ihn jetzt einfach mal an. Der tatsächlich da war, er hat Fotos gemacht für uns, wir haben sie auch gepostet. Moritz H. hat die Tickets gewonnen, er hat den lustigsten Tweet, wie wir fanden, geschrieben. Und er war der einzige, der aus Köln kommt. Und deswegen, und wir dachten auch, die alle haben so ironisch teilgenommen, wie, da kann ich nicht und sowas, wo man auch nicht mehr trennen konnte. Irgendwie, wo ich dachte, wie machen dann seriöse Gewinnunternehmen eigentlich, Gewinnspielunternehmen, wie lösen die das denn, wenn jemand ironisch teilnimmt. Und er meinte dann, habe ich ihm geschrieben, ja du hast übrigens gewonnen als den Glückwunsch, er meinte ja wie jetzt, aber ich kann noch gar nicht. Er meinte, du kannst erstens und zweitens nimmst doch beide Tickets, das ist das scheiß Arschloch, aber du hast was gewonnen, freu dich gefälligst darüber. So und der war jetzt da, dem hat es auch Spaß gemacht, Entschuldigung, und den rufen wir jetzt an. Und den rufen wir jetzt an, ich habe die Nummer. Ja. 5141.
Das heißt, ihr müsstest nur 48 Folgen auf den zweiten Teil des Podcast-Ufo-Telefonstreichs warten.
In Folge 1 und in Folge 49, jetzt ist es wieder soweit.
Stefan, schmeiss den Apparat an!
Äh, wie machen wir das jetzt?
Wow, wow, wow, wow!
Ja, chill mal kurz.
Wie machen wir das jetzt kurz logistisch?
Kommst du kurz rum, dass wir beide theoretisch...
Ich sitze auf dem Sofa, du kannst rankommen. Ich kann jetzt das Sofa schlecht zu dir rübertragen. Hörst du ihn denn jetzt, wenn ich ihn auf laut stelle? Ja, davon gehe ich aus. Moritz, so. Aber wollen wir erst so tun, als wären wir jemand anders? Wir tun so, als wären wir vom Gesundheitsamt. Ne, eine Umfrage. Hallo, hier ist das Statistische Gesundheitsamt. Können wir eine Umfrage vielleicht durchführen bei Ihnen?
Ja, okay.
Wie oft in der Woche haben Sie Geschlechtsverkehr? Wäre die erste Frage.
Deinmal, ich bin Popkasuferhörer.
Ach dammit, er hat es schon rausgefunden. Das war natürlich auch super sicher auch Geschauspieler jetzt von uns.
Martin Weber hier, Kriminalpolizei Köln. Hallo, guten Tag, wir hatten eine Frage, wo waren Sie denn gestern Abend? Ja, wir lassen diese Rollenspiele. Man, warum können wir keine Pranks, Alter, das ist doch scheiße. Wir können keine Rollenspiele mehr seit Folge 13, weil die Community hat uns zerstört. Also, hallo Moritz, wie geht's dir? Ist er jetzt eigentlich Hörergast eigentlich? Zählt es jetzt nach, Cordula ist es schon Hörergast oder ist es... Du bist der zweite Hörergast, herzlich willkommen in der Puffopedia, du kriegst auch einen Beitrag. Was machst du denn gerade, machst du Sport oder wo bist du denn? Ich bin gerade unterwegs zu einem Kumpel. Ja, ja, ja, ähm, ich hab's mir fast gedacht, dass ihr mich gleich angerufen, ja? Ja, ich hab nämlich nach deiner Nummer gefragt, und zwar weil wir wissen wollten, wie dir Jimmy K. gefallen hat. Es war super. Ihr nehmt gerade auf, ne? Soll ich erst mal hochgehen und dann ruft ihr mich noch mal an oder könnt ihr das nicht rausneiden? Ihr schneidet doch immer, oder? Nein, wir schneiden nicht. Wir wollten heute mal eine Folge machen, wo wir nicht schneiden. Also bitte bring jetzt einfach deine Anekdote zu Ende und dann legen wir auf. Der machte das Bild doch gerade, er will noch kurz. Okay, ja, Jimmy K., wie war's? Super. Es war sehr schwer, jemanden zu finden, der mitkommt.
Warum? Ja, weil ich weiß nicht, weil meine Freunde wahrscheinlich alle kein Englisch können. Und deine Freundin? Hä, meine Freundin auch nicht. Okay, deine Mutter? Na, bitte irgendwo hin. Die war weg, die habe ich auch gefragt. Okay, und wen hast du dann gefunden? Deinen Vater? Ich habe, der auch. Hast du Geschwister? Den Bruder von einem Kumpel, ja, alle weg. Wo sind die denn alle? Die sind seit 13 Jahren weg, ich weiss nicht, wo sie sind. Vielleicht bist du auch einfach nur weg und die sind nicht... Genau, wie viele Leute in deinemkreis müssen weg sein, damit du eigentlich weg bist, ist eine gute Frage.
Was ist denn passiert mit deiner Familie?
Ja, die waren in München.
Und was ist dann passiert?
Ja, also, dann habe ich nach Freunden gesucht, die haben sehr lange, sehr ausgiebig Kette gefunden, bis kurz vor der Show habe ich den Bruder von einem Kumpel gefunden, der gerade in Köln war. Und der hatte Bock, der hatte richtig Bock. Der wusste, kannte Jimmy K. nicht, ist aber mitgekommen und hat sich köstlich amüsiert. Also von da aus habt ihr uns beiden einen sehr schönen Abend. Aber wie war denn sein, das entschuldige uns ja als Humorfüchse, wie ich uns ja immer nenne, wie war denn so sein Humor? Was hat der so erzählt, hat er Geschichten aus seinem Leben erzählt, waren es untenrum Witze, viel Pipi-Kacka-Titten? Ja, der hat ja, der erzählt ja einen Witz nach dem anderen sozusagen. Ja, alles dabei, was ich mag. Pipi-Kacka-Witze, untenrum Humor. Ja, aber auch politisch relevant und gesellschaftskritisch. Ja, das habe ich meist nicht verspungen. Kannst du dich an einen Gag erinnern, der dir besonders gut gefallen hat? Wir lieben ja Fremdcontent. Ja, genau, und ich kann so gut Witze nacherzählen. Der hat eine Entweder-Oder-Frage gestellt, das war nice auch nicht an die kate das war ein guter witz an den aber das ist eine gute frage publikum als sms geschrieben habe ich gedacht waren noch mehr vom neo-magazin da ja verstehe guck an das lustige ist dass bei den die verbindung immer genau dann aussetzt, wenn wichtige Trigger-Weiß kommen. Die Pointe ist, ja. Und ich denke, okay, okay, und dann verbindet er die Verbindung ein bisschen. Wie lange hat er gemacht? Er hat gesagt, eine Stunde, in zwei Stunden gestreckt, hat er auch reingehalten. Es waren wenig Deutsche da, habe ich mir gedacht, er waren fast nur Engländer. Ja, die Deutschen. Wie hat denn die Kartenübergabe funktioniert, wie habt ihr das gemacht? Ich hab ihn getroffen, in Deutsch. Wirklich? Du triffst dich mit Hörern. Meet and Greet, klar. Wie soll ich dir die Karte denn sonst gegeben? Ja, ich hab noch mal aufgeregt. Okay, dann Moritz, jetzt mal ganz kurz, wie war denn das Treffen mit Stefan, wie hast du ihn dir vorgestellt und wie war er wirklich? Also ich hab ihn mir grösser vorgestellt und lustiger. Hahaha, du scheiss Arschloch. Aber hattest du denn ein bisschen Respekt, also warst du ein bisschen schüchtern oder kam dir gut ins Gespräch? Warst du starstruck? Nee, ehrlich gesagt nicht. Aber du warst nervös schon? Ich habe gedacht, nee, ich war eigentlich nicht nervös. Ich dachte, wir unterhalten uns länger, aber ich musste auch arbeiten und du musst ja auch wieder... Ich musste leider nach Hause, deswegen habe ich mich ein bisschen, habe ich so derzeit auf die Uhr geguckt, nervös und dachte mir, wann hört er endlich auf zu reden, kann ich jetzt endlich, wann ist es sozial akzeptiert zu gehen. Aber du hättest ihm gerne noch ein paar Fragen gestellt, oder? Weil er hat ja ein, führt ein aufregendes Leben, er hat viel Erfahrung gemacht. Ja, genau. Du kannst ihm jetzt noch eine Frage stellen. Du kannst uns jetzt die Fragen stellen. Äh, jetzt, jetzt bin ich so auf dem spot jetzt weiss nicht was ich
fragen soll ich hätte auch glaube ich keine fragen gestellt hast du denn themenwünsche für die folge noch wir haben bald gehen auch auf folge 50 zu der wahlung war nicht so eine hörer verbundene folge machen aber wünscht dir irgendwie sachen von uns die wir mal ansprechen ihr könntet mal sagen, wer sich schon so beworben hat, den ihr besuchen sollt und dann mal überlegen, wen ihr nehmt live. Ja, das ist bestimmt sehr spannend, das machen wir. Okay, hast du noch coole Vorschläge oder? Nein, leider nicht. Okay, du gehst zu einem Freund, was ist das für ein Freund, ist ja cool. Ja, geht so. Wie gesagt, ich hab ja nicht so viele, da muss man mit dem zufrieden sein, was man hat. Und was macht ihr heute Abend? Keine Ahnung, in dem Magazin gucken wahrscheinlich. Chillen einfach. Ja, genau. Chillext man ein bisschen, wir machen auch eine chillexte Folge, ihr chillext. Ja, nächstesstes Mal kommt es vorbei, dann machen wir Donnerstag zusammen eine Folge. Leider keine Zeit, tut mir leid. Also ihr guckt das Neo-Magazin jetzt irgendwie zusammen oder so, ist das so ein Ding bei euch? Nö, wir treffen uns mal jede Woche, irgendwann mal an einem Tag, ja und dann ... Okay, also wir müssen dann leider weiter, wir haben noch einen Termin. Ja, die Verbindung ist leider ganz schlecht, wir müssen auflegen. Moritz, Marco, ich freue mich, dass wir dich erreichen konnten, dass du einen schönen Abend hattest bei Jimmy K. Florentin und ich wünschen dir und das ganze Team wünschen dir von ganzem Herzen ein schönes Leben. Toi, toi, toi. Ciao! Netter Kerl. Ganz, ganz. Interessanter junger Mann, hat sich aber gut entwickelt. Ich finde auf dem Foto sah irgendwie ein bisschen unsympathisch aus. Ja, wir haben auch so lange überlegt, ob wir nicht einfach diese Karte aussuchen sollten, um irgendwie, weiss ich nicht, Frauenkontakt zu bekommen. Aber wir haben uns dann auch entschieden, einfach Moritz zu nehmen, er war die Save-Wahl. Ist das ein gutes erstes Date auf eine Jimmy-Kar-Stand-Up-Comedy? Ich weiss nicht, ich finde so Konzerte und so Stand-Up-Shows. Schon sehr speziell, gerade auf Englisch halt, nicht jeder Mensch spricht Englisch, aber auch so gut, dass die Gags ankommen. Ja, vor allem die ganze Zeit zu lachen ist, glaube ich, auch einfach keine gute Erfahrung so. Also du willst nicht die ganze Zeit neben mir sitzen, wie ich da mit meiner seltsamen lache, ahaha, die ganze Zeit daneben irgendwie, ahaha, dass ich gar nicht fassen kann, was ich gerade höre. Ich glaube, schlimmer wäre es, wenn sie die ganze Zeit nicht lacht. Dann würde ich auch die ganze Zeit denken, so scheiße, fuck, das ist so, wenn man einen Film aussucht und dann gefällt der anderen Person den Film nicht und dann denkt man sich die ganze Zeit, kann man sich auf den Film, den man selber vielleicht gerne mag, die konzentrieren. Was ist dein Lieblingsbild? Der will beplant und du die ganze mit so einem offenen Mund die ganze ganze Erinnerungst. Hast du das gesehen?
Ach, was ist das?
Was ist das denn?
Hallo? Also kann man auf sich auf den Film, den man selber vielleicht gerne mag, in die Konzentration. Und du die ganze mit so einem offenem Mund die ganze Erziehungstelle. Hast du gesehen? Was ist das denn? Die Szene? Die meinte ich. Ja, und dann keine Reaktion kommt halt, ja, schade. Naja, was würdest du empfehlen, gutes erstes Date, Stefans Flirt-Tipps? Was ich richtig geil finde, also wenn es dir wirklich wichtig ist, würde ich abgefahrene Dinge machen, zum Beispiel Heißtuftballon oder ein Boot mieten, Tretboot mieten meinetwegen. Ich meine, hier in Köln kannst du dir bestimmt, ne, im Rhein, zwei Menschen sind gestorben, weil sie die Tolle wieder gekommen sind. Wie verantwortungsbewusst müssen wir eigentlich mit Tipps umgehen eigentlich? Wir haben jetzt ein paar Hörer. Stell dir vor, wegen uns sterben zwei Leute im Tretboot im Rhein. Ja, kann gut sein. In so einem schwarvenförmigen Tretboot. Nee, aber irgendwas Tolles. Also in Köln gibt es halt diese Seilbahn, wo man quasi über die Stadt fliegen kann. Man fliegt nicht, weil man in einer Seilbahn befindlich ist, aber... Das ist ein Flugzeug, oder was? Korrekt. Okay. Da kann man halt über die Stadt schweben. Und das fände ich halt geil. So eine Aktion halt. Ich glaube, fliegen ist beim ersten Date gar nicht schlecht, oder? Wohin denn? Einfach einen Flug. Einfach mal nach Amsterdam oder so und dann wieder umkriegen. Ja. Oder direkt so in Urlaub, so direkt committen, direkt sagen... Vor allem, weil man am Flugzeug, wenn man fliegt, dann lernt man ja auch die ganzen … Auf geht ja was schief. Das Flugzeug hat meistens Verspätung, du musst sehr lange warten, du musst sehr lange Zeit überbrücken. Das sind diese ganzen Situationen, wo dir Verwandte auch tierisch auf die Nerven gehen. Und wenn du diese ganzen nervigen Stationen schon beim ersten Date durchmachst, lernst du die Person viel besser kennen. Ja, es ist ja so, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wisst, aber Extremsituationen schweissen ja Menschen sehr zusammen tatsächlich. Jetzt du mich jetzt schon. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wisst. Eure Hochwohlgeborenheit. Was sollst du sagen? Nee, dass Extremsituationen ja Menschen sehr eng zusammenschweissen und so ein Flugzeugabstürz ist eigentlich auch ideal. Tatsächlich. Also kann man nur drauf pochen eigentlich, drauf hoffen. Ja, wenn man nicht stirbt, dann hat man einfach ein gutes Leben. Die bei Lost sind ja auch alle wahnsinnig gut miteinander klargekommen. Ja, das stimmt. Gute Serie, bis aufs Ende. Rauchmonster habe ich nicht verstanden. Übrigens die Serie habe ich komplett bei Wikipedia nachgelesen. Ich habe die erste Folge geguckt, dachte ich mir, okay, ist mir zu langsam erzählt, aber alle reden darüber, ich will die Story jetzt wissen und da habe ich mir die ganze Story bei Wikipedia durchgelesen. Die ganze Handlung, alle Staffeln.
Wie viele Wikipedia-Artikel hast du schon komplett gelesen?
Das ist eine gute Frage, ich glaube keinen richtig.
Ich glaube, schon viele. Also ich bin oft auf Wikipedia unterwegs. Wir hatten ja zum Beispiel als One-Liner-Thema in der letzten Neomagazin-Folge Julians Blog, der wegen seinem Auschwitz-Kommentar Probleme bekommen hat, er zuurteilt wurde wegen Volksverhetzung, und da habe ich halt auf die Wikipedia-Seite von Auschwitz geschaut, einfach, ob da irgendwie Comedy-Potential irgendwo drin liegt, ob man dann zum Beispiel so einen Gag machen könnte, wie, aha, er meinte ja gar nicht das Konzentrationslager, sondern die berühmte Sehenswürdigkeit. Genau, die berühmte Sehenskirche Auschwitz, oder er meinte das ja gar nicht, aber Auschwitz hat leider überhaupt nichts zu bieten, ausser dem KZ, deswegen, bisschen blöd. Jetzt sind wir schon wieder bei Auschwitz, tatsächlich, genau wie letzte Folge. Ich verstehe nicht ganz. Also er wurde jetzt wegen Folksverhetzung zu 15. Folks, er hat sich über die Musikrichtung lustig gemacht. Folksverhetzung. Er wurde zu Folksverhetzung. Verletzung in Niederlande, in die Niederlande. Wurde er, sagen wir mal, verurteilt auf 15 Jahre Bewährung, nee, 15 Monate Bewährung. Nein, auf 15.000 Euro Geldstrafe, auf 15.000 Jahre Freiheit, Strafe und 3 Euro Geldstrafe. Okay, und sechs Monate auf Bewährung, glaube ich, und 15.000 Euro Geldstrafe. Kann uns das auch passieren? Ähm, ja. Tatsächlich ist ein guter Punkt. Was müssen wir jetzt sagen, weil ist es ja tatsächlich öffentlich? Eigentlich ist es gar nicht so... Bei ihm war doch so die Nummer, er meinte ja, der Richter versteht keinen Spaß. Der Richter meinte ja, du hast Scheiße gebaut, das ist nicht cool gewesen, das war auch nicht lustig, das kann man nicht auch als Kunstfreiheit verstehen. Und er meinte dann auch, der Richter war einfach ein lustiger Typ, er hat einfach keinen Spaß verstanden. Herr Block, wie lautet Ihre Verteidigung? Ja mein Gott, ja macht man Witz! Das war's im Grunde. Dankeschön, setz ich hin. Also, wer in einer Weise die geeignet ist, den öffentlichen Frieden zu stören, gegen eine nationale, rassische, religiöse oder durch ihre ethnische Herkunft bestimmte Gruppe,
gegen Teile der Bevölkerung oder gegen einen einzelnen, wegen seiner Zugehörigkeit zu einer vorbezeichneten Gruppe oder zu einem Teil der Bevölkerung zum Hass aufstachelt, zu Gewalt- oder Willkürmassnahmen auffordert. Wenn ihr jetzt gerade erst einschaltet, wundert euch nicht, ihr seid beim Einschlafen-Podcast. Herzlich willkommen. Paragraf 130 Strafgesetzbuch, das heisst wir müssten jetzt... Wow, das fände ich einen geilen Podcast. Das Strafgesetzbuch vorlesen. Das heißt, wir müssten jetzt zu Gewalt gegen eine religiöse, rassische und nationale Gruppe aufstacheln. Haben sie schon. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt sagen würden, tötet alle Schweden, ist es im Grunde schon Volksverhetzung eigentlich, oder? Ich glaube, das hat noch... Ich glaube, es wurde weniger in der Geschichte gesprochen, das hat ausgesprochen, welcher Satz? Tötet alle Schweden. Oder schwedet alle Töten, nee. Oder tötet alle Juden. Ist klar die Antwort, oder? Warum? Du verpackst gerade deine Volksverhetzung. Ich verpack gerade meine Volksverhetzung in einem humoristischen Kommentar. Also welche dieser Sätze wurde in der Geschichte häufiger gesetzt? A. Tötet alle Juden, B. Ausländer raus, C. Vergast Florentin, nein, Florentin ist vergeben, ist schon vergeben. Oder D. Alle Christen müssen sterben. Ich hab's jetzt nicht gesagt, das war jetzt eine indirekte Rede, weil wir es ja als Quizfrage formuliert haben. So kann man es nicht noch drum. Das ist tatsächlich... Ich glaube, wer wird Millionär, wenn nicht alles als Quizfrage verpackt hätten. Ein Riesenproblem, ja. Wow, wow, wow. Da steht jetzt tatsächlich Paragraf 130 Absatz 2b, solange die Aussprache als eine Quizfrage verpackt ist, ist die Strafe nichtig tatsächlich. Cool. Ist tatsächlich eingebaut. Kann man ganz gut machen. Ich dachte erst, du lügst, aber dann hast du das Wort nichtig benutzt. Da dachte ich mir, da kommst du gerade nicht drauf, das muss da stehen. Ich war auch sehr froh, dass ich es geschafft habe, den Satz durchzuziehen und nicht vor kurzverändert nochmal gestolpert zu sein. Ja, und mit nichtig zu beenden vor allem. Ja. Sag mal. Oh Gott. Machen wir einen kurzen Einblick in Stephans Privatleben. Hör auf, wenn man in jedem Scheiß, in jedem Scheiß vollkommen ist, um die Ecke. Nein, lass uns doch mal ganz kurz über die Avocado reden. Weil in Stephans Leben ist einiges passiert, in seinem Privatleben, auch in seinem körperlichen Wohlbefinden. Und da möchte ich einfach mal ganz kurz reinstochen in dieses kulinarische Bienennest, das der Stefan hier vor mir ausgebreitet hat.
Was ist da los?
Liegt da was zwischen dir und Avocado?
Ich war dir noch nie so dankbar in meinem Leben.
Wir kennen uns jetzt schon ein paar Jahre und du hast mir diesen Montag eine ganz neue Welt eröffnet.
Und ich bin dankbar dafür, dass du mein Leben auf den Kopf gestellt hast.
Du hast mir, es fing an, wir gingen in Netto, wir gehen öfter mal in Netto, wir lieben Netto. Und wir hassen Penny, wir lieben Netto. Was mit Norma? Norma ist okay. Kit, Hit. Hit ist grossartig. Kick, Kit. Und dann hast du mich zu diesen seltsam geformten, birnenförmig geformten, Birne, die aber diese schwarze Pestbeulen eigentlich aussehen, geführt. Ich dachte mir, was ist das? Was genau ist das? Florentin, als wäre es das Normalste der Welt, Avocado. Das ist eine Avocado. Und da dachte ich mir, was genau hat er jetzt damit vor? Florentin greift öfter mal zu seltsamen Dingen und ich greife meistens auch dazu, Fehlkauf meistens, aber dann hast du mir diese Avocado gezeigt
und ich habe mich gefragt, was macht er jetzt damit?
Und du hast gesagt, ich schmier mir das
aufs Brötchen. So als wäre es
nichts. So was, so was
müsst ihr euch vorstellen, das haut er einfach
in einem Nebensatz raus, unser Florentin.
Ja, so bin ich.
Ich bin nicht aufzuhalten.
Wir sind Draufgänger, das haut es im Nebensatz raus.
Ich bin Grenzgänger. Ich dachte mir, what? Ist das möglich, eine Frucht aufs Brot zu schmieren? Und dann hast du mir gezeigt, wie man die perfekte Avocado findet, indem man die ein bisschen eindrückt, indem man jede anfasst, die im Supermarkt da ist, ein bisschen eindrückt und guckt, wie hart die sind. Und dann kann man die sich einfach aufs Brot schmieren. Einfach noch, also Avocado-Hälfte auf dem Brötchenseite, Salz, Pfeffer drüber, Zapzerrapp. Es ist auch die perfekte Menge. Es ist perfekt, es ist wie Butter zu schmieren quasi. Es ist unfassbar und danach kannst du einfach, ich frag mich, also ich kann gar nicht reden, weil ich so aufgeregt bin, aber du hast keine Verpackung, aber du kannst quasi einfach daraus so löffeln und aufs Brot spieren und schmeißt dir die Avocado weg. Ist perfekt! Ja! Und ich frag mich, was ist noch alles möglich? Ich mein, es schmeckt auch supergut mit Salz und Pfeffer. Ja. Wenn man nicht einfach irgendwie was kauft, was man aufs Brot spieren kann. Ich brauch keine Marmelade mehr. Nie wieder. Kürbis vielleicht? Na, Kürbis ist nicht mehr. Kürbis könnte vielleicht eine ähnliche Konsistenz haben, ich weiss es nicht. Ich hab jetzt eine neue Welt entdeckt, habe aber Angst, dass die Welt da schon wieder vorbei ist, weil es keine andere Frucht gibt, die man auch so...
Ja, die Tür ist offen, man denkt sich, ich gehe durch die Tür durch, aber dahinter ist direkt eine Wand.
Es ist auch nur so eine ganz kleine, so ein usliger Abstellkammer, also mit ganz vielen Avocados.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, mega gut, seitdem habe ich jeden Tag Avocado gegessen und...
Es gibt ja diese Avocadosorte Hass, ne, das steht ja manchmal auf der Avocado steht Hass drauf. So heisst halt einfach die Sorte. Ist ja irgendwie so ein argentinisches Wort oder so ein Kram. Und es gibt tatsächlich Verschwörungen. Was übersetzt bedeutet wie Hass. Ja, genau. Oder Schach. Keine Ahnung. Und da gibt es tatsächlich so eine Verschwörungstheorie, die sich auch so mit Strichcodes und so beschäftigt. Die sagen, Produkte, auf denen Strichcode sind, haben irgendwie schlechte Energie, weil die Energieströme irgendwie gestört werden.
Also jedes Produkt. Mehr oder weniger, und die müssen die erst so aus. Und es gibt tatsächlich manche Bioläden, die dann auf ihren Strichcode so Xe durchgemacht haben, was den Strichcode sich nicht stört, aber tatsächlich die Energie neutralisiert, was ich eine absolute Frechheit finde, weil solchen Vollidioten sollte man nicht nachgeben. Aber tatsächlich haben die auch auf einer verstörungstheoretischen Seite geschrieben, dass wenn das Wort Hass auf Avocado steht, dass dann auch die Energieströme irgendwie gelenkt werden, einfach weil Hass ein negatives Wort ist. Und das ist echt albern, weil da ist es einfach langweilig. Das ist eine langweilige Verschwörungstheorie. Ich sage, wenn eine Verschwörungstheorie müssen aufregend sein und abgefahren, dann habe ich auch Spaß daran. Aber jetzt auf die Idee zu kommen, dass wenn Hass auf einem Produkt steht, dass es dann schlechte Energie verbreitet, da sage ich, nee, don't be boring. Das finde ich ist die einzige und wichtigste Regel des Lebens. Don't be boring. Man kann den größten Scheiss erzählen der Welt, solange man nicht langweilig ist, das ist alles okay. Weißt du, das ist okay. Solange du unterhältst dabei, solange du die Welt ein bisschen Zeit ein bisschen kürzer machst. Genau, Volksverhetzung ja, aber langweilig nein.
Und ich finde, auch da sollte man nur bestrafen, wenn Volksverhetzung keinen Unterhaltungswert hat und einfach nicht lustig ist oder nicht aufregend ist, dann bestrafen. Ich glaube aber so ähnlich ist es auch verfasst im Grundgesetz. Also so ähnlich. Es sei denn, man muss lachen. Mindestens drei H's müssen fallen. Hahahaha ist dann schon genug. Schreibst du in Konversationen eher Lachsmilies oder haha? Ich schreib haha.
Aber auch nicht so oft, ne? Ich schreib hahaha eigentlich, dreimal meistens. Nee, du eigentlich, also bei mir machst du oft, ganz selten machst du nur hahaha's. Oft lässt du einfach so ausklingen und sagst später haha im Gespräch. Ich sammle die ganze Lacher und sobald ich dich sehe, dann lache ich so lange an für die ganzen geilen Tweet-Ideen, die du mir schickst, die ganzen tollen Gag-Ideen. Apropos Verschwörungstheorie, du hast mir einen Podcast gezeigt, du hast mir davon erzählt und ich habe mir den jetzt angehört, der sogenannte Serial-Podcast. Uralt schon, hat wahrscheinlich schon jeder da draußen gehört, der sich für Podcasts interessiert. Stefan hängt natürlich wieder hinterher, hat heute die Avocado entdeckt, eine Frucht, die einfach von Menschen seit Jahrtausenden domestiziert wird. Morgen kommt er mit Dummibärchen um die Ecke. Leute, ihr glaubt nicht, das sind Bären, aber klein und fruchtig. Ich habe so eine längliche gelbe Frucht entdeckt. Was ist denn da los? Was ist denn das? Die kann man schälen. Naja, weiss nicht. Aber unfassbar. Also ich meine, es gibt den Einschlafen-Podcast, haben wir schon oft erwähnt. Ja, hilft einem die Rede, also langsam halt, die reden noch ein bisschen näher im Mikro und freuen sich einfach, wenn man zuhört. Entspannende Themen. Und ich sag mal, es ist ein bisschen entschleunigter, die reden auch immer ein bisschen langsamer als wir, sodass man einfach gerne mal die Augen zumacht. Und es fallen nicht so Wörter wie Mord und Blut. Und plötzlich kommt eine schwarze Gestalt am Fenster vorbei und Ah! Das finde ich auch immer so lustig, wenn im Allenschlafen Podcast Lass uns doch mal zu Gast sein, bitte. Und dann zwischen den Dingen auch mal so, ah! An der ganzen Zeit, Todmord! Mord! Ah! Und das, der Serial-Podcast, für die es nicht kennen, ist einfach so eine Journalistin, die einfach jahrelang recherchiert hat und einfach so einen Mordfall aufrollt, neu, und man halt die Original-Telefonate, die sie geführt hat, mit Opfern und Tätern führt und so weiter, mega cool, aber es ist das Gegenteil des Einschlafens-Podcasts, finde ich, weil ich dachte mir so, okay, ich habe so mein Handy dann so neben das Bett gelegt, habe schon die Augen zu gehabt, alles dunkel und so, und irgendwann lag ich einfach mit so aufgerissenen Augen im Bett, aufgerichtet, weil es einfach unfassbar, es war unfassbar nervenaufreibend, weil die einfach so einen krassen Mordfall hat aufrollt, und du plötzlich auch quasi die Telefongespräche hörst, Telefonate hätte man auch sagen können, mit Opfern oder wirklich potenziellen Tätern, die verurteilt sind aus dem Gefängnis und neben dir hast du einfach dein Handy, wo du jemanden daraus sprechen hörst, der womit dich jemanden umgebracht hat. Es ist so gruselig. Wie hast du den konsumiert? Tatsächlich unterwegs. Immer wenn ich von A nach B laufen musste, habe ich den
angeschmissen und mir dann ordentlich mal ein bisschen Audiogold in die Ohren gedrückt.
Glaubst du, man läuft eher von A nach B oder von B nach C? Wie viele Leute verpassen die Chance, von B nach T zu laufen?
Die Frage ist, kommt man jemals bei B an oder ist man eigentlich immer auf dem eigentlichen Weg nach C?
Oh, Aristoteles, der Weg ist das Ziel.
Hab das Aristoteles gesagt?
Bin ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher. Pythagoras. Was ist dein aktueller Buchstabe, an dem du gerade bist? F, und wo bist du gerade auf dem Weg dahin? Ich bin auf dem Weg zum K, aus dem Grund, weil ich einfach ein bisschen verlaufen war. Und ich habe mich umgehört und K wäre dann der nächste befindliche Buchstabe. Ich bin bei der 99 gerade, das ist ein bisschen, ich bin komplett abgeraten tatsächlich.
Ich war ja, vorgestern war ich beim Sushi-Emodi, da dachte ich mir auch, hups, da war ich ein bisschen falsche, falsch abgebogen. Aber hast du das Cis gesehen? Das hat mir immer gewunken, von dem Berg runter. Mach mal ein Cis. Wir sind halt ein bisschen entspannt. Ich merke es gar nicht. Also ich finde es eigentlich ganz angenehm, dass wir uns heute mal ein bisschen zurücklegen. Also ich mache den Laptop jetzt mal zu. Ich habe heute so viel gefressen den ganzen Tag über. Es ist echt so schlimm, wir haben heute wahnsinnig viele Süßigkeiten gekauft, weil wir einen Beitrag machen über einen Süßigkeitenverkaufsautomaten tatsächlich. Und allein, ich habe einfach keine Willenskraft. Wenn Süßigkeiten am Tisch stehen, muss ich die essen. Da gibt es einfach nichts drumherum, das ist wirklich katastrophal. Ich habe da keine
Willenskraft, das geht einfach nicht. Es muss einfach weg, das ist wirklich so, das ist wie
wenn ein Berg, manche Menschen müssen einfach auf diesem Berg klettern, weil einfach weil er da
ist und du fragst sie, warum denn so ist doch, aber so nein, einfach weil er da ist, der ist
einfach so undeniable so, das ist auch so, der muss halt beklommen werden. Und das ist bei mir
Es ist ein Schuss, das die Schuss, die wäre halt Special Interest, ich überlege gerade, wo ich nicht zögern kann. Ich glaube, bei einem guten Wein. Ich dachte so, bei einem guten Trampolin. Wenn ich an einem guten Trampolin vorbeiläufe, sage ich, da kann ich nicht reinzahlen. Da juckt es mich schon. Entschuldigt mich für die nächsten zwei Wochen. Ich war bei einem Trampolin über dem Meer. Das war geil. Da hast du noch unten geguckt und dann hast du das Meer gesehen. Und da dachte ich mir, Trampolin ist geil, aber selbst wenn es ist Reis oder so, weil ich war ein sehr dickes Kind und hatte eigentlich konstant die Angst, dass unter mir der Boden zusammenbricht. Das war eigentlich meine konstante Angst. Jede Brücke, die ich überquert habe, war eine potenzielle Todesfalle. Und deswegen war das eigentlich sehr angenehm zu wissen, okay, wenn ich da durchfalle, dann bin ich zumindest im Meer einigermaßen gut aufgehoben. Von daher war das sehr angenehm für mich. Ich kann nicht schwimmen, aber es würde mich zumindest auffallen. Ja, tatsächlich. Ich war mal am Grand Canyon, da ist ja oben dieser Glasswalk. Ja. Weißt du, wo man dann quasi Kilometer tief nach unten gucken kann. Da waren dann Leute, die waren auch ganz nett, diese Guides, weil man darf da auch mit so speziellen Schuhen, muss man da rumlaufen. Guides ist geil, ne? Und da waren dann so Leute, die gefragt haben, woher ich kam, weil die meinen strangen Dialekt bemerkt haben. Und dann haben die mir gesagt, okay, du kommst aus Deutschland, ja, das Glas hier kommt auch aus Deutschland und wir haben Risse festgestellt. Ihr könnt euch ja gleich unterhalten, auf der gleichen Basis. Ja, so ähnlich, das Glas kommt aus Deutschland, du kommst aus Deutschland, wir haben Risse festgestellt, wie kann das sein? Und ich so, what? Du bist direkt dafür verantwortlich. Erstmal will man, wenn man drei Kilometer in Höhe auf einem Glasboden steht, nicht hören, wir haben Risse festgestellt. Ja. Erstens, zweitens... Man will nicht dafür verantwortlich gemacht werden. Genau, weil ich aus dem Land komme, wo das Glas halt herkommt. Und da habe ich mich da so sehr defensiv gefühlt, weil ich mir dachte, nein, ich habe hierfür bezahlt, ihr sollt mir das zum Erlebnis machen. Ja. Wärst du gern mal dick? Okay, ich akzeptiere diese Frage zunächst einmal. Aber warst du jemals dicker als jetzt? Ja. Ja, wirklich? Weil du bist jetzt eigentlich schlank, könnte man sagen, so halt dabei einfach. Ich bin normal schlank, aber auch nicht so schlank, dass Frauen sagen würden, wow. Also ich bin… Na ja, gut, aber wie schlank muss… Das weiss ich, kommt auf die Frau an wahrscheinlich, aber ist halt die Frage… Also ich war mal ein bisschen dicker, irgendwann bin ich halt sehr schnell gewachsen und seitdem bin ich dünner. Durch die Trägheit der Masse ist dann sozusagen alles nach unten gegangen. Es ist alles nach unten gerutscht, aus meinen Füssen rausgerutscht. Ja, ich war mal dicker und es war nicht schön, nee. Aber ich war nicht so dick wie du als Kind. Also wie du als Kind warst. Aber wärst du gern mal wieder dick oder ist es... Für einen Tag, ja. Ich wäre alles gern immer für einen Tag. Aber wärst du mal einen Tag so richtig fett, so richtig, richtig, so 300 Kilo Fett? Nee, das finde ich nicht zu krass. Aber allein wie sich das anfühlen müsste vom Körpergefühl hier. Ja. So einfach so auf sich die eigene Armlehne zu sein. Weil Armlehne ist ja eine geile Sache. Also immer wenn ich eine Armlehne sehe, sage ich, geil, super, der Tag wird gut, Armlehne, mein Arm ist gerettet für heute. Aber wenn du halt selber so eine Armlehne hast, ist es doch mega gut. Ja, vor allem, du kannst ja, es gibt ja verschiedene Arten von dick sein, und es gibt ja die eine Art, wo du halt so dick bist, es unangenehm ist, in zum Beispiel Flugzeug sitzen zu sitzen. Aber dann gibt es irgendwann so dick sein, dass man sich auf sich selber quasi, dass man wie so ein großes Kissen ist. Dass man sein eigener Sitz ist, ja genau. Und dass man auf sich selber quasi auch einschlafen kann. Und sein eigenes Boot auch so. Du brauchst halt auch keine Fahrzeuge mehr. Die können ja auch einfach dann den Kopf runter machen und es liegt halt weich. Und die können dann einfach so Dinge auch auf sich abstellen. Das finde ich auch eine ganz geile Sache. Das ist richtig gut. Und die können einfach dann auch auf sich selber einschlafen, wie so ein Fatboy. Oh, passt sogar. Ups. Ja, finde ich ganz gut. Das finde ich echt ganz gut, ja. Es ist nur diese, in Extrem fühlen wir uns halt, glaube ich, auch wohl. So entweder, so das ist das Humor. Doch, Humor funktioniert in Extrem, wir auch. Wir funktionieren wie Humor. Je extremer eine Situation, desto mehr fühlen wir uns da wohl. Was war denn die letzte extreme Situation, in der du dich wohlgefühlt hast? Du sitzt den ganzen Tag zu Hause, isst deine scheiss Beefy-Roll und masturbierst vor deinem scheiss Kampfen. Weinend.
Ja, weinend. Ich fühl mich ja nicht wohl.
Pfeifend.
Ne, aber hast du mal so extreme gemacht, so eine Extremsportart oder sowas?
Nein.
Bungee jumping.
Hallo, du kennst mich doch natürlich nicht.
Du bist zu faul, ne?
Ich hab, glaube ich, seit zwölf Jahren das Land nicht mehr verlassen.
Ich bin einfach zu faul.
Was war das Weiteste, wo du jemals von zu Hause weg warst? Ich glaube, Nordengland, so Achilles Islands, so der nördlichste Punkt vielleicht. Und da hat es dir gefallen? Und in Sizilien war ich auch mal. Da hat es dir gefallen? Ja. Guck mal, Da habe ich es doch bewiesen. Und der nächste Anrufer bei Stefans Late Talk. Wir begrüssen Felix. Hallo Felix. Hallo. Hallo Felix. Nein. Entschuldigung, also ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt. Also ich heisse Felix. Hallo Stefan. Hallo Felix. Du bist durchgekommen, gut durchgekommen? Ja genau, ich rufe hier an aus einer Telefonzelle. Ich habe sehr lange gebraucht, die Telefonzelle zu finden tatsächlich, aber jetzt wo ich dran denke, ich hätte eigentlich auch mit dem Handy anrufen können, aber jetzt bin ich schon hier. Alles klar Felix. Ich bin jetzt extra in die andere Stadt gefahren, da wollte ich fragen, ob ich da die Kosten für die Fahrt. Nein, natürlich nicht. Felix, was ist der Grund, warum du anrufst? Wie geht es dir? Ich bin in Geldnot gerade. Ist das der Grund, warum du anrufst? Das ist der Grund, warum ich anrufe. Ja, ich habe sehr, sehr viel Geld verloren tatsächlich, weil ich hatte so eine Hose, da war, ich habe immer ein Messer dabei, so einen Teppichschneider und der hat mir die ganze Hose aufgerissen und da habe ich sehr viel Geld verloren tatsächlich über die Jahre hinweg und jetzt habe ich kein Geld mehr tatsächlich. Ist dir das mittlerweile aufgefallen, dass du die Hose bewechselt? Das ist mir gestern aufgefallen tatsächlich, als ich auch mein Messer verloren habe tatsächlich dadurch. Was natürlich das Problem einerseits behoben hat, also das Lochproblem, also die Ursache ist behoben, das Loch jetzt allerdings noch nicht. Also es wird jetzt nicht noch schlimmer, das Loch wird nicht grösser, was gut ist. Das Problem hat sich mehr oder weniger selbst gelöst und ich hoffe eben, dass sich jetzt auch mit den finanziellen Problemen auch auf die Art selber löst. Hast du die Möglichkeit, die Verwandte oder Freunde an Geld zu kommen, um zumindest in der anderen Stadt zu kommen? Die sind in einer anderen Stadt tatsächlich, weil wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt in die andere Stadt gefahren, um die Telefonzelle zu finden und ich habe leider auch kein Geld mehr, jetzt hier zurückzukommen. Das heisst, ich weiss es nicht, also wie gesagt, falls ihr mir irgendwie ein bisschen Geld da überweisen könnt oder halt geben könnt, damit ich auch wieder in die Stadt zurückkomme, wäre halt ganz nett eigentlich. Hastest du jemals viel Geld? Würdest du die jemals als, ja, sagen wir mal, ausgewogen finanziell ausgestattet betreffen? Ich hatte sehr viel Geld, ja. Ich bin ja, ich arbeite ja beim Amt. Danke Felix. Danke. Wir können dir leider nicht helfen. Aber danke trotzdem, schön auch noch. Als nächstes bei Stefan Slaytalk. Wir begrüssen Tim. Hallo Tim. Hallo Stefan! Oh, da höre ich gerade. Wir müssen kurz Pause machen. Tim, wir rufen dich gleich wieder zurück. Herzlich willkommen bei Stefan Slaytalk. Hier sind wir wieder. Und wir begrüssen zurück in deritung Felix, hallo. Hallo Stefan, Felix nochmal. Jetzt wartet hier gerade ein Mann vor der Telefonzelle tatsächlich darauf, auch an das Telefon zu können. Womit bezahlst du gerade, Felix? Ich habe tatsächlich jetzt mal die letzten zwei Euro, die ich hatte, in die Telefonzelle geworfen und genau, oh, ich glaube der Mann hat mein Messer gefunden. Auf jeden Fall, er hat zumindest ein Messer in der Hand und er zeigt es mir gerade. Das ist nett von ihm. Das ist tatsächlich ein schöneres Messer, als ich hatte. Ich frage ihn vielleicht mal laut fuchtelnd und angsteinflössend, ob er das Messer zurückgeben kann. Ja, Moment, ich kriege leider die Tür auch nicht auf, weil er steht jetzt gerade direkt vor der Tür und er hält die Tür zu. Aber er zeigt mir sein Messer nochmal. Es ist ein schönes Messer. Wahrscheinlich hat er gemerkt, dass ich mein Messer verloren habe und will ihm jetzt seines geben, aber ich kann gerade nicht mit ihm kommunizieren tatsächlich, also ... Egal, was du jetzt machen willst, ruf auf gar keinen Fall die Polizei an, das würde ihn nur für unsichern. Wir warten noch kurz die Situation ab und wir melden uns gleich bei Felix wieder. Genau, bis dann. Ciao. Herzlich willkommen. Hallo, ich bin's nochmal. Sie hören Stefans Late Talk. Wir begrüssen Sonja. Hallo Sonja. Hallo Stefan. Hallo, wie geht's dir? Mir geht's gut. Sonja, was ist der Grund, warum du anrufst? Ach, weisst du Stefan, das ist echt immer so schwierig. Also das Problem ist mit meinem Freund. Also ich bin mit ihm jetzt schon seit dreieinhalb Jahren zusammen und ich bin mir einfach nicht sicher, ob er irgendwie die Beziehung noch so ernst nimmt irgendwie. Also er hat in den letzten Tagen so ein paar Aktionen gebracht, wo ich mich schon gefragt habe, warum macht er das? Also er tut immer häufiger so, als sei er blind und er hat sich jetzt auch so einen Blindenstock besorgt, aber er ist nicht blind. Also ich weiß, dass er nicht blind ist. Was sagt er, dass er nicht blind ist? Ja, ich meine, jemand, der blind ist, hätte nicht so eine Freundin wie mich, oder? Ich bin sehr übergewichtig, massiv übergewichtig tatsächlich, Adipositas 3, sehr, sehr fett. Ganz kurz, das interessiert mich privat, bist du so fett, dass du auf dir selber einschlafen kannst? Ich kann auf mir einschlafen, ich lebe auch auf mir selbst tatsächlich. Ich habe ein kleines Grundstück und habe mir jetzt da auch eine kleine Wohnung gebaut und bin da auch sehr glücklich, aber mein Freund auf jeden Fall, er tut so, als sei er blind und er hat sich jetzt so einen Blindenstab gesucht und er hat dann, also er trifft mich auch mal mit dem Blindenstab, er läuft dann so durch die Wohnung und haut mich dann manchmal so mit seinem Blindenstab und dann sage ich, Schatz, warum haust du mich? Und dann sagt er, ja, ich sehe ja nichts, aber teilweise holt er auch sehr sehr weit aus und trifft mich auch direkt ins Gesicht mit dem Blindenstab. Er sagt aber immer wieder, ich bin blind, ich bin blind, ich weiss nicht, wo ich bin, was ist das, was treffe ich hier? Und dann sage ich, aber Schatz, ich bin's doch, kennst du mich nicht, du kannst doch sehen, du schaust doch Fernsehen gerade. Aber er haut dann immer wieder mit dem Blindenstab auf mich drauf. Seit wann geht das so? Das geht jetzt seit acht Monaten so tatsächlich.
Und es ist einfach ein bisschen unangenehm, weil ich nicht weiß, wo das herkommt.
Weil ich ja weiss, dass er nicht blind ist.
Hast du dich mal darauf angesprochen?
Ich habe mich bis jetzt noch nicht darauf angesprochen, tatsächlich.
Ich frage immer nur, Schatz, warum, also du siehst ja, wo ich bin.
Ich habe mich ja auch seit zwölfeinhalb Jahren nicht vom Fleck bewegt.
Ich habe so eine Tonne bekommen tatsächlich zu meinem Geburtstag, da bin ich drin. Und deswegen weiß er ja auch, wo ich bin. Also auch selbst wenn er erblindet wäre jetzt vor einem Jahr, wie er behauptet, wüsste er ja trotzdem noch, wo ich bin, weil ich ja immer in derselben Tonne drin bin. Aber komischerweise kommt er mit dem Stock immer. Wann gab es eine Situation, die das Blindsein ausgelöst haben könnte? Was sagt er dazu? Also er sagt, er ist blind geworden, als er das letzte Mal mit mir Eis essen war. Da hat er gesagt, da hat er so viel Eis gegessen, dass er blind geworden ist. Das kann ich mich tatsächlich nicht daran erinnern, weil da war ich gerade im Ausland. Sonja, was hältst du davon, wenn du, um sicher zu gehen, dass er blind ist, ihm einfach zwei Gabeln in die Augäpfel rammst? Ja, wir haben gar keine Gabeln mehr tatsächlich. Die Gabeln hat er alle verkauft. Ja gut, aber jeder andere spitze Gegenstand täte es auch. Ein Löffel. Einfach um sicher zu gehen, Sonja, dass er wirklich blind ist. Ja, gut. Das war's mal wieder bei uns, Stefan's Late Talk. Und ich gebe zurück zum Podcast-Ufo. Da sind wir wieder. Finde ich toll, mal so ein bisschen Fremdkornet, oder? Also das war jetzt Robby und Klaus. Wir haben reingeschaltet in eine neue Sendung. Das ist ein Comedy-Duo aus Bottrop tatsächlich, die jetzt gerade einsteigen ins Geschäft, ein Podcast-Geschäft. Wenn auch ihr eine tolle Idee habt, ein tolles Comedy-Duo seid, dann fragt doch einfach die Medienkuh. Comedy-Trio. Dann eher radionukular, würde ich sagen. Das ist, glaube ich, eher was in der Richtung. Was sind Podcasts, die du gerade aktuell hörst? Du hast mir vorgeworfen, ich wäre anachronistisch mit meinen Ideen. Nee, Arschloch, habe ich gesagt, nicht anachronistisch. Das war so, glaube ich, falsch verstanden. Ich hörte tatsächlich gerade die zweite Staffel Serial.
Wow!
Ja, mein Gott, deswegen habe ich sie auf Abbau geschlagen.
Du kannst es nur nicht sein, dass sie in den Jahren gibt es nicht hinterherhängt, während du die zweite Staffel hörst.
Nein, die zweite Staffel ist relativ neu tatsächlich.
Ja, das ist die perfekte Ausrede dafür, dass du mich gerade so genannt hast.
Und Script Notes kann man sich immer gut anhören, ist ein Podcast von Drehbuchautoren für Drehbuchautoren und ist sehr, sehr schön.
Tatsächlich kann, sehr gut.
Script Notes.
Es ist soweit, ich mache jetzt
mein Salamini-Combo auf.
Aber kannst du ganz kurz vorlesen, was zumindest draufsteht,
woraus dieser Teig besteht?
Es ist wirklich,
also ohne Scheiß, wenn man diese Packung umdreht,
es ist nur Text. Und es ist einfach nur eine Salami in einem ... Aber auch in Dialogform geschrieben, ne? Das ist seltsam. Hallo, hallo Frank. Es ist nur eine Salami in einem Teig und die ganze Rückseite ist ein riesen ... Okay, es sind ganz viele Sprachen. Hallo Frank, wie viele Kalorien hat dieses Produkt? Du, ich glaube, dieses Produkt hat etwa 777 Kalorien. Das ist ja ganz schön viel. Wie viel davon ist denn Zucker? Keine Sorge, nicht nur viel ist Zucker. Ich werde jetzt mal so schön ich kann und so interessant wie ich kann die Rückseite vorlesen. Sie hören Salamini-Combo von Marco. Weizengebäck mit Mini-Salami. D-A-C-H-Zutaten, Weizengebäck 51 %, Weizenmehl, Trinkwasser, Rapsöl, Palmöl, Kokosfett, Zucker, Hefe, Vollei, Weizen, Weissei. Trinkwasser? Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Trinkwasser und Wasser? Weizen, Eiweiß, Entschuldigung, Emulgator, Mono- und Diglyceride von Speiselfettsäuren, Säuerungsmittel, Zitronensäure, Natrium, Zitate, Essigsäure, Juditisch Speisesalz, es ist wie gesagt, es ist nur ein Brötchen mit einer Salami da drin, ich weiß nicht was, Magermilchpulver, Süssmalkepulver, Weizenmehl, Verdickungsmittel, Gurken, Gurken, Guacan, Guacan, Guacan, Guacanmehl, Guacanmehl, ich glaube es ist ein Bayer, der jetzt geschrieben hat, er wollte Gurkenmeel schreiben aus Guacameel. Mini Salami. Gargameel, glaube ich. Unscheiß, die Mini Salami ist nur 49%. Salami. Es ist nur 49% Mini Salami da drin. Ja, natürlich, der Rest ist Brötchen. Aber es ist wesentlich mehr als 50% Salami da drin. Naja, Schweinefleisch, jüdische Speisesalz, Traubenzucker, Gewürze, nach wie wir es gebadet ... Glaubst du, wir haben nichts mehr zu sagen, Stefan? Glaubst du, dass wir langsam an dem Punkt angekommen, wo wir einfach keinen Content mehr haben, wo wir einfach Dinge vorlesen müssen? Ja, wir haben auch überlegt, ob wir das Genre-Podcast einfach in die neue, ins 21. Jahrhundert katapultieren, indem wir sagen wir mal einfach Geschichten erzählen jede Woche aufs neue. Oder Sudoku vorlesen. Ja. Lecker. Ich habe noch eine Avocado tatsächlich für heute Abend, habe ich mir aufgehoben. Mh, boah. Werde ich mir jetzt gleich einverleiben. Ich möchte mir gar nicht vorstellen, was mit dir und dem Avocado heute Abend noch geht.
Vor allem die Avocado, was ich ganz toll finde, hat einen kreisrunden Tischtennisball-grossen Kern.
Ja, und tatsächlich in die vernünftige Guacamole wird auch der komplette Kern noch reingerieben, tatsächlich.
Was findest du an diesem Funfact so interessant, dass du es jedes Mal erzählt hast? Ja, dass man Kerne ja in der Regel nicht isst. Das macht dich verrückt. Ja, das macht mich wirklich verrückt. Man isst Kerne. Bei Erdbeeren isst man Kerne auch mit. Nein, das sind keine Kerne. Erdbeere sind ja Gemüse, tatsächlich. So, wir wollen Fashion Content auch diese Woche wieder präsentieren. Deswegen hat Florentin jetzt sich drei tolle Geschichten ausgedacht, die er heute noch erzählen will, und ich freue mich darauf. Auf diesen Teil der Sendung freue ich mich schon seit eigentlich heute Morgen. Es ist ja interessant, weil man denkt ja in Sprache, und man kann sich ja oft nicht vorstellen, wie jemand, der mit einer anderen Sprache aufgewachsen ist, die Welt vielleicht ganz anders sieht. Und zum Beispiel habe ich mir überlegt, in der englischen Sprache ist es ja so, da liegen ja die Worte Grape und Rape sehr nah beieinander. Das heißt, immer wenn du Grape sagst, sagst du auch Rape. Und wir können uns gar nicht vorstellen, wie unsere Welt aussehen würde, wenn Weintraube und Vergewaltigung einfach sehr ähnlich klingen würden. Was hätte das für einen Eindruck auf unser Unterbewusstsein, auf unser gesamtes Sprachverständnis? Ja, vor allem Jerk. You are a jerk. Heißt ja so viel wie, du bist ein Vollidiot. Aber Jerk off heißt ja ... Das heißt ja, du bist ein Wichser. Ja. Nee. Es heißt eigentlich sowas Vollidiot. Ja, Wichser heisst auch Vollidiot. Ja, aber Wichser ist halt ein viel, viel schlimmerer Ausdruck. Dieses Mh, danach, das war international für, das war kein mehr Bullshit. Zeichen. Ja, da fällt kein Beispiel ein, aber das ist doch ... Ach Mann, ey! Nur weil du uns seit Monaten dieses Bitte überlegt hast, was semi-gut ankommen wird, sagt von Such, und ich will jetzt dein Beispiel zu einfällen, lass mich nicht fällig machen von dir.
Da schneide ich raus. Nein, wir schneiden heute nicht. Das ist die Regel.
Nee.
Ja, okay. Und glaubst du, dass die jetzt quasi ein eher sanfteres Verhältnis zur Vergewaltigung haben.
Ja, auch einfach Poesie, Reime.
Also Reim ist ja ein kulturell sehr zentrales Element eigentlich.
Und es wird ja einfach durch die Sprache definiert, was ein Reim ist und was nicht, welche Worte zusammenpassen.
Und wenn du jetzt einfach Grape auf Rape reimen kannst, im Deutschen aber nie auf Vergewaltigung,
so wie du gar keine guten Reime findest, könnte es etwas sein, dass das Wort Vergewaltigung in Poesie oder in Rap, also im Sprachgesang, schlicht nicht vorkommt, einfach weil es keine Reime darauf gibt, weil du es einfach nie als letzte Silbe verwenden kannst. Das heißt, du definierst ja schon mit dem Sprachvokabular das potenzielle Vokabular der Kunst und Kultur und Poesie. Und das, da möchte ich mal einhaken, dass das einfach eine Frechheit ist. Ich habe ein Gedankenexperiment gelesen neulich in der Wissenschaftszeitung, ohn Scheiss. Was ist denn eine Wissenschaftszeitung jetzt schon wieder? Bravo. Mediamarkt-Prospekt. Die Bravo ist für mich eine Wissenschaftszeitung jetzt schon wieder?
Bravo.
Die Bravo ist für mich eine Wissenschaftszeitung.
Und ich fand die Frage extrem gut.
Also angenommen, man würde die Menschheit nullen, quasi, man würde, die ganze Menschheit hätte ihr Wissen noch,
aber du würdest sie komplett alles wegnehmen, was sie besitzen, quasi nur auf eine Welt setzen, die nur aus Natur besteht. So steinzeitmäßig. Saarland-mäßig. Genau. Wow, cool. Saarland-Gags. Wow, cool. Sehr gut. Ist das das Ensemble-Denken, von dem du immer redest? Wow, cool. Wie lange würde die Menschheit brauchen in diesem Stadium, um ein iPhone zu bauen? Nur ein einziges funktionsfähiges iPhone. Finde ich mega spannend. Und ich glaube in etwa genau so lange, wie sie gebraucht haben. Weil du brauchst alles, was davor passiert ist, brauchst du für das iPhone. What? Außer die Wissenschaft halt. Ja eben, aber das ist ja das, was so lange dauert. Bis du mal bei A² plus B² und C² angekommen bist, dau ja schon zehntausend Jahre. Und da bist du instant. Wie lange müssen, wie lange braucht, glaubst du, brauchen die Menschheit dafür? 40 Minuten. Bis sie ein funktionsfähiges iPhone aus der Natur haben. Ja, wenn alle zusammenarbeiten und wirklich intensives Brainstorming betreiben und du viele kleine flinke Kinderhände hast, die das Titanium aus dem afrikanischen Berg kratzen, relativ schnell gemacht. Die andere Frage, die ich dir stellen möchte, ist, wie alt müssten Menschen mindestens werden, damit eine funktionierende Gesellschaft entsteht? Also angenommen, alle Menschen sterben im Alter von 14, würde dann eine funktionierende Gesellschaft entstehen oder nicht? Doch, klar. Ich sage mal, es hätte ja einen Grund, warum sie mit 14 sterben. Weil sie dann dementsprechend in der Altersschwäche sterben, weil sie ausgewachsen sind. Aber sie haben die körperliche und geistige Reife eines aktuellen 14-Jährigen. Ja, hatten denn damals die mit 40 gestorben sind und aussahen wie ein Greis? Nein, damals waren Leute mit acht Jahren ja schon uralt. Die sind ja damals im Alter von drei, vier Jahren gestorben in der Eiszeit oder so. Die Steinmenschen, Urzeitmenschen, die waren ja mit zwei. Die waren wahnsinnig klein, die waren wahnsinnig klein, zwölf Zentimeter groß teilweise. Mit vier war nichts mehr mit Mammutjagd, mit vier hängst du noch zu Hause rum und hast irgendwie Bilder gemalt oder so. Du gehst um fünf Uhr ins Bett, während du Aktenzeiten in die Südde und guckst. Und dich einfach zu Bingo und du triffst mit den anderen Vierjährigen. Uncool, mega uncool. Ja, ich weiß nicht genau. Finde ich ganz interessant. Hey, boah, man muss noch mal ganz ehrlich sagen, wie du dir rumlungerst gerade. Ja, ich bin völlig weggedreht. Ich finde das so unangenehm, du läufst seit Wochen. Die Firma sind junge Studentencharaktere, die sich hier freuen, jeden Tag sich ein Hemd anzuziehen, ein Jeans anzuziehen und zur Arbeit zu kommen, in einem gepflegten Outfit, der Bart sitzt, die Frisur sitzt, komm herein morgens gut gelaunt mit einem Kaffee to go, du kommst jeden Morgen mit so einem schluffigen Rocket Beans T-Shirt und einer Jogginghose herein. Ja, jeden Morgen weint Sonja auf der Treppe, wenn sie dich sieht. Nein, ich habe einfach eines Tages beschlossen, ich trage noch Jogginghosen, weil es einfach mega bequem ist. Das ist mega bequem. Und du sparst dir die Unterhose. Nein, doch. Sag mir bitte die Unterhose an. Ich will das nicht sehen. Nein, aber es ist wirklich mega entspannt. Und es ist ein anderes Körpergefühl einfach. Du bist einfach schon von morgens einfach im Slack-Modus. Du bist einfach schon direkt, sagst, oh Leute, was geht ab, komm. Nee, aber ich muss sagen, also für wen trägst du kleidung für dich oder für die umwelt für die zuschauer für die hörer ja aber warum ja aber ich glaube das war genau der switch den ich gemacht habe umgeschalten von weil ich habe mich früher immer sehr sehr gut gekleidet und hat den sehr exquisiten unangenehm gut ist aufge ich sagen. Es ist dir dann aufgefallen, so oi oi oi oi. So ein bisschen blenden. Ups, der Poncho, der jetzt da trägt. Fabian ist sehr gut getroffen. Poncho wäre doch eigentlich das Äquivalent zur Jogginghose für den Oberkörper eigentlich für dich, oder? Also nächste Woche oder nächsten Monat kommst du dann mit Jogginghose und Poncho hier. Ich wollte einfach mal die Burka ausprobieren, weil die Burka löst alle Probleme, du chillst einfach dein scheiß Leben.
Deine Frisur ist völlig egal. Frisur ist scheißegal, ob du Pickel im Gesicht hast, scheißegal, du chillst einfach dein Leben, du machst gar nichts mehr. Aber es ist nicht zu warm draußen, da gibt es kurze Burkas irgendwie. Bestimmt in einem Heute-Show-Sketch oder so, denn der Mini-Rock für die Burka oder sowas, toll Stefan Titze, dass wir jetzt schon in dem Niveau angekommen sind, wow. Wir unterstützen uns, denn wir sind ein Team, wir sind Ensemble-Denken, wir machen das zusammen. Das ist unser Projekt und wir haben uns gern. Aber würdest du, angenommen, du würdest den ganzen Tag Homeoffice betreiben, würdest du dich dann anders anziehen? Nee, weil wir halt auch keine anderen Menschen sind. Und zu Hause trage ich immer eine Jogginghose, manchmal auch gar nichts. Was unangenehm ist, weil ich wie gesagt im Eikerschaus wohne. Und viele Kinder immer direkt vor der Wohnung spielen. Sehr viele Kinder, auch bei mir in der Wohnung sind. Ja. Da kommt die Katzenklappe rein, ne? Fischklappe. Entschuldigung, ich habe echt immer noch Husten, kriege ich nicht ganz weg. Hau noch was raus. Alles klar, ich wollte noch was raushauen. Dazu muss ich ein bisschen uncool ausholen. Ich habe, wie gesagt, ich gucke gerade die Serie Comedians in Carl's Gilding Coffee mit Jerry Seinfeld, mega cool, muss ich jedem empfehlen, auch uralt, was ich auch erst entdeckt habe. Stimmt, vier, fünfeinhalb Jahre.
Fünfeinhalb Jahre alt, locker, die Folge mit Barack Obama, die ich gestern gesehen habe, auch locker schon acht Jahre alt, egal, die fand ich echt lustig, weil der hat den dann besucht und der konnte halt nicht mit dem, er lädt immer Comedians ein und fährt mit denen irgendwo hin, trinkt mit denen Kaffee, fährt wieder zurück, alles cool. Barack Obama konnte er nicht abholen und wegfahren mit ihm, weil Barack Obama nicht in einem fremden Auto das Grundstück des Weissen Hauses verlassen darf. Das heisst, er sitzt dann vorne irgendwie so ein Typ, so ein Secret Service Typ wahrscheinlich, so ein Typ einfach, der ihm sagt, du kannst ihn nicht rausfahren, Herr Präsident. Das heisst, was ist der Präsident eigentlich? Er ist eine Art Geisel. Er ist wirklich so gefangen in seinem Kosmos, er ist wirklich eine Art Geisel, Leute sagen ihm, du bist gefangen jetzt für immer, solange du das Amt ausfüllst, nehmen wir dich gefangen, wie so ein Haustier.
Du darfst nicht raus, mach was für uns, regiere für uns, mach uns eine bessere Welt, aber du darfst nicht raus, du darfst nicht das Haus verlassen. Präsidentschaft ist ein Geben und Nehmen. Er kann dafür halt auch einen Atomkrieg anzetteln, muss dafür aber halt auch mal sagen, okay, du kochst dir nicht dein eigenes Essen, weil du könntest ja daran sterben. Ja, und dann ist das halt so ein Typ und der steht dann draußen, irgendwie so ein schlecht bezahlter Typ, der einfach ihm sagt, Herr Präsident, du darfst nicht raus. Vor allem, da denke ich mir, ist er nicht eigentlich der geheime Held der USA, der Typ, der den Präsidenten verbieten darf. Ja, oder die Leine, an die der Präsident hängt, ist das nicht eigentlich der wahre Patriot? Die Fussfessel, die der Präsident trägt. Ja, der Scharfschütze, der jederzeit bereit ist, abzudrücken. Ja, finde ich mega interessant. Aber allein wenn du dir zum Beispiel anschaust, was diese ganzen Wahlkampfkampagnen ja kosten, ja Millionen, Abermillionen fliessen da rein, da kann man dann schon mal sagen, wenn der Typ da mal Präsident ist, dann hat der auch verdammt nochmal nicht zu sterben, weil es einfach auch scheiße teuer war, den zum Präsidenten zu machen. Klar, da gibt es Leute, die sagen, auf gar keinen Fall, ist mir scheissegal, was der will,
wir haben da wahnsinnig viel Geld reingebuttert, die Partei und die Leute,
dann fähren die durchs Land und machen diese Transparente und so.
Und jetzt stirbt der Idiot.
Und jetzt denkt er, er könnte irgendwie Smarties essen und stirbt er an so einer Smarties-Schale erstickt.
Was soll das denn? Ist ja klar, dass die Leute das nicht wollen.
Glaubst du, es wurde mal ein Tod eines Präsidenten krasser gemacht, als er war, weil er eigentlich nur irgendwie an eine Avocado gestorben ist? Ich glaube, John Wilkes Booth war der eigentliche Held, weil er Lincoln erschossen hat, nachdem der irgendwie an einem Oreo-Keks erstickt ist. Eher erstickt wäre. Ja, er erstickt wäre und er sagte, nee, so kann er nicht in die Geschichte eingeben, ich erschiesse ihn jetzt noch. Ich glaube, und hat ihn so zum Märtyrer gemacht. Eigentlich, wenn du wirklich hinter dem Präsidenten stehst, musst du eigentlich, hast du die moralische Pflicht, ihn zu erschießen, um ihn über seinen Tod hinaus zu einem Märtyrer, zu einer Figur, zu einer Leitfigur zu machen. Wenn du jetzt Barack Obama in seinem letzten Amtsjahr noch erschießen würdest, würde er aber sowas von fucking Sanders gewinnen. Ist schon ein bisschen zu spät, ne? Nee, aber er würde schon als Legende eingehen. Die Mehrheit würde sagen, danke, jetzt hat auch ein bisschen genervt, ein bisschen den Jump gescharkt, oh, geil, und, ähm, ja, ein bisschen reicht jetzt auch. Ja, nee, aber ich glaube, das ist eigentlich, von dem Jahr hätte es machen können. Ich glaube, so ein George Bush hätte sich gewünscht, in seiner letzten Woche erschossen worden zu sein, weil der ist jetzt als Mega-Loser der Geschichte, keiner mag ihn, er ist ein Trottel, Depp hat den ganzen Irakkrieg und so einen ganzen Scheiss verborgt. Ich glaube, der hätte schon gesagt, er wäre schon geil gewesen, wenn ich noch erschossen worden wäre, um zumindest als Held in die Geschichte eingegangen zu sein. So hat er bei Ebay auch angeboten, der nämlich erschießt. Genau. Oh, warte mal, ich muss noch ganz kurz bei Ebay gucken. Du verkaufst Stühle. Ich verkaufe tatsächlich gerade Stühle und ich habe tatsächlich jemanden gebeten, für mich zu bieten einmal und ich
weiß, dass es gute Idee war. Das darfst du öffentlich und scheiß nicht sagen, das ist wirklich
strafbar. Nein. Das ist hochgradig strafbar. Das ist ja nicht strafbar. Und das ist doch
Stimmung gerade, was ich mache, dich in die Pfanne zu hauen und erst zu sagen, das ist strafbar,
was du gerade erzählt hast. Weil dann werden Leute, die wachen dann nochmal auf aus dem
Halbschlaf und sagen, Moment kurz, was ist da gerade passiert? Was ist das denn für ein
Strafbestand? Tatbestand? Das öffentliche Verunsicherung des Marktes. Paragraph Zwitz mit Smitz Die öffentliche Verunsicherung Verunsicherung, sag bitte nicht drölf Die öffentliche Verunsicherung des Marktes. Nein, ist das Betrug oder was? Verunsichert. Verunsichert. Verwirrung. Verwirrung. Moment. Hä, sechs Designerstühle für 300 Euro, was? Die Verwirrung des Marktes. Verunsicherung des Marktes. Nein, das ist doch Angebot und Nachfrage, das ist doch die Idee von Kapitalismus, dass du Dinge so teuer verkaufst, wie es geht. Und wenn da so ein Typ mit einem Schnurrbart in einen Laden kommt. Du könntest ja auch nicht neben die Avocados im Netto stellen und sagen, hm, ich gebe ihnen 30 Cent pro Frucht. Da würdest du auch dem... Doch, das kannst du sagen. Dann sagt der unterbezahlte Netto-Pakistani halt, nos comprendos alemandos, oder sagt einfach nein. Das war gerade nicht das richtige Beispiel. Du kannst nicht...... Ich glaube, die Hälfte der heutigen Podcast-Folge ist dafür raufgegangen, dass Stefan Beispiele sucht. Und alles führt ins Nichts. Pass auf, die Nachfrage treibst du ja künstlich in die Höhe. Indem du Leute engagierst, die das von dir kaufen wollen, die es aber gar nicht wollen. Du manipulierst Angebote und Nachfragen, die man auch dem mag, tatsächlich. Ja, aber du kannst doch, wenn du einen Limonadenstand aufmachst, kannst du doch deinem Bruder sagen, hey, komm mal vorbei und kauf eine Limonade, damit andere Leute denken, hey, der hat gute Limonade, das ist doch nicht verboten. Das ist aber auch nicht vergleichbar. Du kannst doch deinem Bruder sagen, was du willst. Das ist nicht vergleichbar, weil du nur eine Sache demnach verkaufst, also das wäre wie eine Auktion. Die dürfen bei Christie's, können die auch nicht sagen, zum Ersten, zum Zweiten, an den Herrn, oh nein, oh, da treibt der mal den Preis in die Höhe, weil er mehr bietet. War es natürlich, aber so für 10 Dollar. Aber du weißt doch nicht, ob er den Preis in die Höhe treibt oder ob er es wirklich haben will. Ich glaube, das einzige, was verboten ist, ist Kartellbildung, dass du die Preise absprichst mit anderen Firmen. Das machst du ja in dem Sinne, indem du anderen Leuten sagst, ich möchte auch nichts, ich gehe jetzt mal kurz raus, weil ich ein bisschen wütend bin über deine Art, wie du mit Ebay umgehst. Ja, weil du sagst, ich hätte Straftat on air begangen und ich mich, oh, er verteidigt sich, uh, bin ich jetzt der Böse oder was? Ja, ich meine, es ist verboten, ich finde es auch nicht cool, wie du damit umgehst. Ich meine, ich war derjenige, der den Preis in die Höhe getrieben hat, aber ich glaube, es ist einfach nicht gut. Also, falls ihr uns anklagen wollt, eine Anzeige erstattet wollt, wegen Volksverletzung und oder Verunsicherung des Marktes, dann einfach an die BTF GmbH, Ostregerstrasse 159. Clever, sehr gut. Da werden die uns nie vermuten. Sehr gut. Ja, gut. Stefan, willst du noch ganz kurz mal erklären, wie ein Mikrofon funktioniert? Als Abschluss. Wieso? Nö, einfach damit die Leute verstehen, was gerade passiert ist. Das hier, was ihr hier hört, ist ein Pop-Schutz. Den da mache ich jetzt mal ab. So klingt es ohne Pop-Schutz. Bop-bop-bop-bop-bop. Also was heißt das, Pop-Schutz bewirkt das? Ist das so eine Art, das ist quasi so eine geballte... Eine Art Kondom. Genau, das ist eine Art, dass ein geballter Luftstrom die Membran eindrückt, sozusagen. Das verhindert das quasi, weil es die Luft ein bisschen streut. Da drin haben wir eine sogenannte Grossmembran, wir sprechen in Grossmembran-Mikrofone, der Marke Sennheiser. Es gibt aber auch noch andere Marken wie Norma, zum Beispiel Penny, oder auch Edeka oder aber auch Lemmy, nicht zu vergessen, Cola, aber auch Shell und Kaffee. Da drin werden quasi die, es sind ja Wellen, Schallwellen, die werden aufgenommen, gespeichert und über Kabel, das weiss ich nicht, hör auf, die Fragen anzustellen jetzt, die werden dann in den Kabel gesendet, rein in den Äther auf die Datenautobahn.
Was ist ein Äther?
Der Übermittler. Da dienen dann in dem Fall Kupferkabel. Die wurden unumigmal geklaut, weil Kupfer kann manabel anverkaufen. Hinten raus bin ich ein bisschen abgedriftet, aber ich glaube, ich habe in etwa verstanden, wie Mikrofone funktionieren. Ja, gut. Danke. Ich finde es immer interessant, dass wir einfach ein paar Sachen erklären sollen. Wir haben einfach schon ein bisschen angehäuft. Nächstes Mal erklären wir, wie ein Flugzeug funktioniert. Einfach mal gucken. Jetzt will ich gerade einen Eimer sehen. Wie funktioniert eigentlich Eimer? Wie läuft das eigentlich? Wie kann man Dinge reinwerfen, wie kann man Dinge rausnehmen? In meiner Schule damals wurden nie viele lustige Sachen gemacht eigentlich. Ich fand immer alle Sachen so ein bisschen, ich lasse mal in der letzten Reihe und wenn jemand einen Gag gemacht hat, bei dem die ganze Klasse gelacht hat, da dachte ich mir immer so, ja, ja. Ganz schlapp, oh mein Gott, sack so in sich zusammen. Aber dann hat jemand einmal, da waren damals diese YouTube-Tutorials und Unboxing-Videos kamen so hoch und hat ein Typ, ein Kumpel von mir damals, ein YouTube-Video gemacht, das einzige Video aus seinem Kanal, wie er diese Luftpolster-Folie erklärt, wie er einfach erklärt, wie die funktioniert und was man damit machen kann und dass man die auch poppen kann.
Das war ein echt lustiges Video, ja. Alles klar, tschau!
Tschau, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal! Und wir sind Neo! Neo, wei, wei, wei, die KW sind Neo.
Freut euch auf nächstes Mal, wenn wir erklären, wie Flugzeuge funktionieren.
Und, ähm, falls ihr wissen wollt, wie ein Raumschiff funktioniert,
rufo, dann heben wir jetzt ab! Ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba, ba,